une bonne dose de concentration en plein
dans le mille julien l'allemand vient
d'enchaîner trois volets à 10 points une
performance assez dur à réaliser c'est
la tranche henning alors les uns la
suite sur la même volée et puis le
répéter volée après volée c'est là où
c'est le plus compliqué
ça fait du bien de tirer 3 10 comme
chaque année cet habitant de la marne
participent au concours de tir à l'arc
de guyancourt environ cent soixante dix
archers sont présents au gymnase maurice
baquet adhérents du club puis en
courtois pendant trois ans julien
allemand revient uniquement dans les
yvelines pour cette compétition cela
fait 25 ans qu'il pratique ce sport il y
trouve de nombreux avantages la
recherche de performance le côté
convivial qui peut y avoir aussi et puis
ça m'apporte beaucoup sur le plan
personnel c'est non c'est un sport assez
complet ça me fait ça me fait vraiment
du bien de voir tir à l'arc julien
l'allemand est l'un des meilleurs
archers de cette compétition yvelinoise
il a gagné trois fois le tournoi
européen des cinq nations en 2004 2005
et 2010 est
si je me trompe pas
j'ai aussi fait d'autres tournois
internationaux en france en belgique en
hollande
en allemagne un au royaume uni tous
n'ont donc pas le même niveau mais
qu'importe ce week end le concours
s'achève par des finales les 16
meilleurs de chaque catégorie
s'affrontent ça permet de faire un
entraînement pour tous les archers que
c'est ça leur permet de s'entraîner pour
les championnats de france où c'est les
mêmes formules louise aurons avec des
duels à élimination directe cette fois
ci je suis un allemand a terminé premier
de sa catégorie arc à poulies de que
leurs assurés ont vu d'autres
compétitions